I think there is going to be some
Republicans who say well I didn't like
Trump but I can put up with it there
will be Democrats who say I wish there
was a younger candidate but it's Biden
that's fine that's already been
happening a little bit but there's a big
share of the country uh I think it'd be
bigger than 2016 that say I just can't
believe these are my choices and that's
going to be a lot of democratic strategy
is that's right then you just stick it
out with buying these are your choices
wait it out like if we beat Trump again
then you don't have to worry about them
in the future uh not in a very inspiring
campaign but not every campaign is
inspiring
[Music]
thank you
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast Ace political reporter for
semaphore formerly of the Washington
Post I got to know him on the
presidential Trail he's a journalist I
turned to to know what the heck is going
on Dave Weigel welcome Dave it's good to
be here good to talk to you again you
too man uh so semaphore you took the
startup leap you've worked at a number
of pubs Washington Post is just about as
establishment as it gets what made you
decide to join the new startup yeah well
I never have been at a startup I I've
been at stuff that was fairly
recently founded I worked for a
non-profit in 2009 that was pretty new
and I worked at slate I don't know 10 15
years after it was founded it still felt
fairly new but never been something
since the beginning I'd known Ben Smith
who's the editor-in-chief for a very
long time and he'd been trying to work
with me for a long time which is nice of
him and uh if you see the publication uh
it it's experimenting with a kind of
publishing stories organizing stories
that is designed everyone hopes I hope
too designed to break through the uh the
impasse that a lot of readers have when
they look at articles the feeling oh I
this article is going to be very
opinionated I don't want to read that
the way that we structure articles is
breaking it down into uh the news some
reporter opinion some alternative
opinion uh while making them good
readable stories I thought that was
interesting so I wanted to yeah I
thought I don't know how many chances I
get in my 40s to try something new so I
want to try something brand new uh well
congrats on it man most people know that
I I love new things startups uh uh a
little bit of risk taking although I
will say I mean most people would
consider working at The Washington Post
something of a dream job uh was it a
tough decision and you know obviously
you know you made like a little bit of
um you know like I guess you were the
subject of some uh kerf waffles I don't
know if that had anything to do with
with the decision to leave the post
no um that wasn't that was never fun and
one thing that you get at the post in
general or to any kind of big
established institution especially in
media is people uh have a hotter
Spotlight on and they'll look for ways
to I guess ways to stoke drama I mean I
I'm a big drama Aficionado of like
YouTubers and and people online we get
to fight with each other I was never
trying to get in a fight but I could see
that that happened sometimes so I would
say people still talk to me I wasn't
really worried people wouldn't wouldn't
talk to me at a different publication I
did find and I knew this would happen
there's people who didn't like the post
at all with some Republicans who just
cut it off and didn't they wanted to cut
the mainstream media out who will talk
to an outlet that's that's new and we'll
we'll
you know give you give you time answer
the question if they've blacklisted the
paper I don't support people
blacklisting the paper but that was
different so it shook up what I did but
less than I mean there's people who just
do 180 degree turns you know they're
working for some app company they get
hire or they they're working for like a
gigantic Tech firm and they work for
some app company and they risk
everything you know they they give up
the stock options like my risk was
pretty low but but it was it was it was
a hard thing to think about but I mean I
had a uh I agree it's a it's a dream job
and especially in journalism where a lot
of things are not buried and not very
safe uh the the post if you were doing
the work and showing up and covering
stories felt very safe and you're part
of a big team that is a good feeling
there's not a lot of that in media so
there are two big things I wanted to
discuss with you I think are in a lot of
people's minds the first is uh the the
debt limit increase uh in DC
um so just to frame this I talked to
about my Insider who said the people who
think this is going to work itself out
are seeing something different than what
I'm seeing
that from their perspective uh the sides
are digging in
um they both think it's going to be a
loser for the other side
um one of the the tougher elements is
that it's kind of got like a fuzzy uh
drop dead date or a timeline where
um treasury came out and said look it's
going to be end of May June 1 um but
then there's some skepticism around that
date some people think you could push it
so so this setup to me is a terrible
setup because you can easily see both
sides playing their hands uh and then
just sliding past the deadline and then
the markets crashing and maybe they they
can't uh actually you know come to to
hammer something out in a matter of
seconds or minutes like it might take
some more time the most important thing
that's changed is the last time we did
this is that the last time happened so
uh there was no precedent in people's
memory in 2011 as a story I was on a lot
about what would happen if the U.S ran
up right to the edge of the debt limiter
went over uh apocalyptic warnings about
what would happen uh what did happen
well they had a deal they kicked they
kicked the can uh there was a credit
downgrade that was enormous news some of
the biggest news of the year that in in
the long run didn't really affect people
at all I feel like it's trivia at this
point that it happened so that's that's
the most uh Vivid thing affecting the
politics right now is that it you have
people who lived through what they were
told was a crisis and nothing happened
that they remember that they remember
being important uh and so that's that is
I think why it took such a long time for
this to build up I mean there might be
some exhaustion reporters who covered
the first round of this and everyone's
12 years older and they think well I
know who this ends you know the old
availability heuristic it happened to be
this way once it's probably gonna happen
to me that way again
um but you're so as you said there is
not a set date on it that's another
thing we learned this time the treasury
will put out an announcement of when
we're going to go over and in 2011 that
was covered as this is it we're all
going to be eating cat food when they
hit that date what it means is that you
hit that date the treasury is going to
move money around extraordinary
circumstances uh so it's going to be an
impasse for a while I think I do think I
keep referring to how people learn from
the last time uh the people who with
money in this which is a lot of a lot of
them have been pressuring the White
House more than the White House expected
to just sign what something that
Republicans in the house give them the
White House's position was we lived
through this literally Joe Biden lived
through this
um we're we've learned that if you treat
this like a real negotiation uh you
don't benefit you end up having to give
something up and you get a credit
downgrade anyway what's the point of
negotiating they also thought I think um
and this can work in politics I'm not
sure it's working right now if you just
don't treat it like it's real uh you
don't treat it like like negotiation is
is legitimate then you can shape the
coverage people say well yeah why am I
paying attention to this to these things
a lot of it is just getting people to
blame Republicans and if they see a
headline that says U.S hit the debt
limit for them to say I wish those
Republicans would deal with it that's
not very
4D 5D chess uh it is just the idea of
waiting until the crisis and hoping that
most people will blame Republicans uh
that has not happened to the degree the
White House thought it would you've got
you know business groups that are saying
just work the religions on this but it's
not blowing them up either they're not
going around the country getting
protested uh people demanding they take
the deal it's a very inside Washington
story at this point oh yeah I think that
you've hit the nail on the head where
each side thinks that if there is a
massive problem the other side will pay
the price yes um you know like the uh I
mean the White House thinks like hey
people are of course going to blame the
Republicans for this and the Republicans
are like they're gonna blame Biden for
this because he's the president uh and
so each of them has a theory of the case
you know I I think that there's going to
be plenty of blame to go around but like
you know I look at this and say
um this is a very nasty setup like this
is not a setup for success
[Laughter]
where because you know the the White
House is saying look we're not going to
negotiate this is a fake negotiation
we're just going to ask for a clean uh
debt limit increase and I do not think
McCarthy and the Republicans can deliver
a clean debt limit increase after
everything they've been through I think
it would cost McCarthy's speakership
um so so I don't think they are going to
get a clean debt limit increase like so
something's going to have to give
yeah and there is stuff to give away I
mean
the it's so dull to get into the way the
way it ended last time you could yo you
can say these two words man because the
two words I'm hearing are permitting
reform
oh yeah so permanent reform is a good
example there's some stuff that that
people basically agree on that could be
included in something that is not clean
um but what happened last time was there
was a the debt limit fight happened in a
larger conversation uh that really was
stoked by well-funded groups P
Peterson's group uh Senate committee for
responsible federal budget there was
it's very weird if you have you know
even a journalist understanding of micro
macroeconomics it was a period where
like the biggest problem facing the
country was not the national debt it was
it was the labor market it was
unemployment
um the biggest problem facing the
country right now definitely not
unemployment it's more inflation so the
conditions were not actually relevant to
do it for a debt crisis in 2011 but what
happened was a huge conversation we all
agree we need to shrink this debt we
spent all this money on the stimulus uh
what can we do to get to the table so
that maybe Republicans are going to
trade tax increases for something else
but what happened last time was it was a
big robust okay there's never been a
crisis like this everyone meeting
everyone in DC to kind of feel by these
these pressure groups everyone's talking
about the debt we should do something
and that's not been happening this time
because you everyone in Washington lived
through a trump Administration that once
it was in power got rid of the spending
spending caps as part of those debt
deals just kept kept plowing ahead and
spending money but Republicans are not
even going as as broad as they did 12
years ago like they went out of their
way this time to not touch any
entitlement program in the deal so that
and I should I could truncate what I'm
saying because in 2011 the idea was this
is so unprecedented this is the time to
do gigantic reforms that we all agree
America must do it's been overdue that's
not the debate this time it's okay well
we need to give into some demands
Republicans have some things that they
want to cut and reverse they want to get
reverse Parts the inflation reduction
act we they want permitting reform uh
they want to claw back spend coveted
money it is less than Republicans were
demanding less time last time because
just I think things have changed and
they're post-trump the Republican party
is not interested in entitlement reform
social security cuts Medicare Cuts
Medicaid Cuts sure but but not the rest
of it so it's a very it's a much smaller
debate which is which is also playing
into this you're not as as invested if
you're watching this from the outside
from Wall Street because
the the deal a deal that would make
Democrats unhappy that would make
Republicans feel like they won something
um you just started to describe it it
would be well we cut we cut some of
Biden's spending priorities and we we
have some environmental uh policies that
Democrats didn't want that we got
through that wouldn't be enormous that
really that stuff that honestly well
functioning Congress could probably just
vote vote on normal for sure like in the
old congresses of 50 years ago could
just say well here comes a crisis what
can we trade so the stakes are the
stakes are lower and it's much
I want to say silly um but it's it's
it's it's having a tougher time getting
into the public Consciousness for all
those reasons you know people live
through it Stakes are lower there's less
being demanded and the white and
Democrats are convinced all right if we
just don't treat this like it's
legitimate that's never we've never
tried that before we've never we've
never just pretended that this isn't
real we can't enough to negotiate what
will happen if we hold that as long as
possible
well I I do want to to uh say on one
level the stakes are higher my read of
the situation is that
um they're gonna play chicken uh and
yeah
um and that they're not going to do the
reasonable thing until they're forced to
do so and by the time they're forced to
do so I think there could be some
significant repercussions I think the
Market's Fragile with these bank
failures and the rest of it I think
confidence is fragile uh like you know
that this is just like a gonna be a
self-inflicted wound
um if they get to a point where it
starts having a real Market
repercussions how do you think this
plays out so one possibility is the
White House gets to the precipice and
says all right uh none of this is real
we're going to find a way to keep
funding the government we're not going
to be taking Hospital hostage in other
ways is that is that aka the trillion
dollar coin yeah I mean that they say
they can't pull off but I'm saying until
until we reach that moment and they
officially rule it out you can't 100
rule that out before the other options
are are much more pedestrian and and and
normal which is okay we we reached this
point in negotiation we're willing to
sign off on a few after not negotiating
roller sign of a few things they wanted
which is I've not negotiated many debt
limit deals or many of these deals like
this but being obstinate saying no
absolutely nothing and then giving part
of what Republicans want
um and then at that point maybe you
throw it to the house and you can put
the onus on Republicans in the house
um will they pass something that's less
than what they demanded and to the
extent the the the the gamesmanship of
this is like that's that's where our
Athens story at the moment the one one
thing I will say though
the Democratic base which remember the
same position where Barack Obama is
running for re-election in 2011 2012. uh
the threat was that Republicans might
tank the economy while he's running for
reelection uh Biden is running for
re-election just announced it the
through the threat is similar
um but there's less apart from just the
losing face there are fewer things being
negotiated that would anger the
Democratic base there was a possibility
that that Obama could have gone in let's
say one of the versions of the of the
debt limit deal had passed Obama could
go in as the first Democratic president
to agree to uh in a very long time on
social security cuts
um what would that have done to the
excitement of the base what would that
what would that have done to democratic
activists we saw how within four years
there was a a primary challenge to
Hillary Clinton there was the Bernie
Sanders campaign what would that have
done I think it would have disrupted
things with inside the party I don't
think anything being negotiated right
now will disrupt things the same way
there would be disappointment by a lot
of liberals uh who say why the president
looks weak for having compromised at all
he should have minted the coin uh I
think bit the coin is a good like way to
just say he should have done something
that just cuts get rid of the whole
controversy but it wouldn't be the same
thing like he betrayed he betrayed us I
think there would if they're in a
permanent reform is something that a lot
of Democrats were going to agree to
anyway I think there will be would be a
backlash from the environmental left on
that uh but most the backlash would be
we don't like it when our team loses
less we don't like it when our team
undermines the the New Deal that was the
risk in 2012 2011.
foreign
we are living in the era of big Tech AI
chat GPT generative tools and these big
tech companies have made it a habit to
pick up everything we are doing online
why should they get our data and where
left out in the cold it's reasons like
this that I use expressvpn to hide my
unique IP address to make it harder for
big Tech to track me and my identity and
activity and encrypt all of my online
comings and goings and it's not like you
have to be a tech whiz to use expressvpn
literally just tap one button on your
phone or computer to activate it you
don't want your family to be vulnerable
and one subscription to expressvpn
covers me my wife and my kids on up to
five devices so stop letting big Tech
leech on your data freely use my link
expressvpn.com yang right now and you
can get three extra months free that's
exp r e s s vpn.com Yang to get
protected with a VPN rated number one by
CNET tech radar and most importantly me
expressvpn.com
foreign
so let's turn to what you just said
about Joe Biden running for re-election
all right so I I yeah I travel the
country and
um when I say to folks hey Biden Trump
rematch they're like groans head shaking
I mean you probably get the same thing
yeah it shows up with the numbers
majority of Democrats uh don't even want
Joe to run again
um and when I say like hey it's got to
be Joe for months people have been like
no that's impossible
[Laughter]
I really think I'm seeing it here he is
it's Joe even now there is some
scuttlebutt that even though Joe's
declared the now it's a video and
everything else
um that there still might be a switch in
nominees uh before the August convention
next year on The Democratic side so is
it Joe Biden uh the the whole way
through uh in terms of being on the
ticket and the general election next
November oh man I think this is an
enormous question uh and uh so I have
the same resp as the same interactions
you do you travel probably more than me
I travel a lot we both travel more than
most people I'd say it's fair to say
right uh and yeah I heard that until the
midterms uh I heard just disbelief that
Biden could run again and even if the
Democrat they maybe they weren't
watching viral videos or you know Super
Cuts of Biden
um mixing up words in a speech or
something they didn't believe the he
can't handle the job stuff but really
since
uh the Afghanistan withdrawal and and
the effects of that I definitely heard
this idea well obviously they're going
to run somebody who's not who's not
Biden is it going to be is it going to
be commonless or an alternative combo
and the midterms uh ended that
conversation because they went so well
for Democrats I think he is the nominee
unless uh something which is always
awkward to discuss I mean some people do
it for political reason I'm just doing
for the Practical what do people tell me
reasons if something happens if he's
much less healthy if he if he's unable
to show up for work if there's some
medical crisis that sort of thing we
don't do not have a uh recent uh you
know TV error precedent for that the
closest you get honestly and I'm not
trying to be glib about it but is uh
Hillary Clinton fading fainting from
pneumonia after uh at the 9 11
anniversary ceremony in 2016. that was
seen as such a crisis for the Democrats
at the time that Donna Brazil the DNC
chair uh the interim DNC chair because
remember Debbie Watson Schultz resigns
over there I remember
and she's admit admitted pretty soon
after election that she started to look
up what are the Alternatives like if
Hillary's sick do we have to how do we
replace her and you know wouldn't you
know it in 360 and the alternative she
she was going to propose or I shouldn't
say she was going to propose the
alternative she came up with you know
instantly was Joe Biden Cory Booker
ticket I was like should we just replace
this ticket with Joe Biden and Cory
Booker
um and they didn't get there but there
was enough of enough of a fear that a
candidate seen as medically unable to
serve could not win the election and so
could that happen to Biden I think I
would not rule it out if you're being
honest you can't rule it out if you are
asking the White House on record a
question it is a rude question asked
they're not going to answer it you know
you talk to a Democratic party chair in
a state they will they don't dignify the
question but that is I it's unusual uh
Gap I've seen between the conversation
from people who were Americans who will
vote
for president in our happy about their
possible choices and the D.C Democratic
conversation was which is not just DC
states of course we'll nominate rejo
Biden again I think that attitude right
now that's dominant there is no interest
in these State parties in in a real
challenge by real challenge what I mean
just let's say a governor who uh could
would hire uh operatives who are very
well known in Democratic politics who
are willing to risk their careers by
going against Biden that sort of
conflict and I am privileging like the
you know media's perspective here why is
that more legitimate than uh you know
Dennis kucinich managing Robert F
Kennedy's campaign there are reasons for
it I mean I I I as far as I'll go is
Kennedy is not running the kind of
campaign you know going to States
getting Democratic uh support talking
about issues that 90 Democratic voters
agree with them on
um Marion Williamson is talking about
those issues just kind of not getting
the attention
um neither of those people is seen in
the states as a as a Biden Challenger
who who could replace who who they think
can beat him and would be the nominee
general election but I don't think Biden
is in danger unless there's a medical
emergency that is so Stark people say
well we thank him for his service but we
need to nominate somebody else and in
that case uh that would be a historic
mess for the for the Democratic party
um matched with the Republican massive
down Trump is is convicted of something
rather in the next year there's not
really a plan if he's the nominee to
dump him and replace him because I think
the difference when I'm comparing those
two situations is that Republican base
as it stands is much more devoted to
Donald Trump than the Democratic faces
is to Joe Biden just the fact he won the
Primary by a landslide
but yeah yeah it's Matt you know you
know this like you can look at the
polling he is respected and Democrats
appreciate him and they love that he's
president but they are not going to if
if let's if if Trump Biden had a medical
emergency there would not be the same
you can't get rid of this guy attitude
I mean you cannot get rid of this guy
attitude not to the left but I'm
splitting here I talked to a lot of Dems
who are eager to get rid of Joe honestly
yes
the way you were laughing I was like are
you disagreeing no you're agreeing but
like make it better oh yeah I'm laughing
at the fact that it's like a republican
base like what
you know go with anyone else even if
Trump is uh behind bars so let's
um so let's explore this further for a
moment um so first let me say that uh I
I uh find it ridiculous that the Beltway
and media conversation is so disparate
from ordinary everyday American
conversation because guess what the
guy's gonna be 82 in 2024. like
actuarially speaking there is uh you
know an almost 50 chance that Joe Biden
does not make it through a second term
uh and there is very very little
confidence in his VP to take over
um and so you know you're looking at the
situation like the average American is
like what is going on here and I've
spent a lot of time with Joe Biden
um not recently but like on the campaign
Trail
um you know he wasn't Tip Top Prime Joe
Biden uh three or four years ago and uh
it's clear that the job has just like it
has everyone else except maybe Donald
Trump it's like taking its toll on him
you know you see you're like holy cow
and by the way I've talked to people who
are around Joe Biden personally now and
they will say to me it's like you know
it's different now even than it was two
or three years ago so the so the fact
that if you have what strikes me as a
very very objective Common Sense
conversation you get attacked as like
ageist Trump enabler blah blah it's like
come on like every American I talk to
just says these three words to me
he's too old that like I get those three
words all the time so uh you know and I
I like you know I mean I think Joe and
Jill are are really great uh public
servants uh you know and and but like
these two things can both exist and be
true
um so it let's say that Joe decides to
uh or not decides to either decides or
you know has a decided Forum where it's
like okay it's next march and he's got a
health problem uh you know and people
looking up saying oh snap so the DNC
um Jamie Harrison right now
um so the the DNC has already come out
and said not having primary debates like
RFK Marion Williamson you know not not
legitimate tough luck uh essentially
um those debates that they existed would
be happening later this summer like this
year so by next march it would already
have been like essentially a debate free
season
um there might have been some states
voting and then Joe uh gets the votes
wins let's say in the current world
um but then he has a health problem and
Jamie Harrison the DNC are like oh snap
like we can't run Joe in the general
um so what does their current day
version of Donna Brazil's uh you know uh
Joe Biden Cory Booker ticket look like
look it would have to be led by the Vice
President and that's one even stranger I
mean if the the fact of a 80 year old
president being being in a discussion of
whether he's too old is is not it's new
but it's it's you explain to somebody uh
from Mars they'll say well that makes
sense I don't know well I guess a year
has passed differently on Mars but they
would get the gist they were translated
into martians it'd be like yeah that's
old
but the uh the that's the part that's
the most vexing for Democrats is that
Kamala Harris uh first female vice
president in history no one's ever made
it this far
um would would be the first female
president if you know it was not made
and wins and the conversation in in
Elite Democratic circles uh and in I
think the county party level is oh we're
just don't think that she could win so
we need to we need to think of something
else you can't just ignore the vice
president Kamala Harris if something
were to happen with Biden uh she would
be that is that is the vice president's
role she would be the error parent I
think it'd be a discussion of
um I I don't think the party you you
could game out fun scenarios I don't
think it's just possible the realm of
the reality we work in
um for the party to say we had a meeting
and and because vice president is
polling kind of badly we were placing
her with somebody else who pulls better
I don't think they could it would be it
would be Harris and there'd be a a DNC
vote over the vice presidential
candidate a lot of horse trading there
that would be difficult that'd be a
controversy who even gets it it's an
ugly situation I mean everyone the
George McGovern losing Nixon is still
the biggest Landslide defeat and like
two-party politics
um in modern American history uh it was
always going to be a loss I think for
Democrats that in that election
based on based on the campaign that
you're running but what really sunk him
and made him unelectable was he dropped
his running mate and he picked a Shriver
after after Eagleton was I think what
would now would now not be a career
render well now would be totally field
then is he had something issues yeah
yeah he had depression he did we wonder
when some uh electroshock therapy
um but the fact that McGovern had to
switch out his opponent the last bit
just I think it'd be impossible I think
it'd be impossible to just not nominate
Kamal Harrison that would be a crisis
that I don't know how party would would
um would bounce back and win the
election now
on paper like all this sounds crazy
because on paper you could say well
there's some Denver there's some
Democrats who pull really well Gretchen
was really popular
um other people with crossover repeal
Josh Shapiro the governor they do have a
bunch of people that if you ask a
democratic strategist they'll tell you
oh can't wait for them to run for
president 2028 but they don't get that
choice because Joe Biden's president
Kamala Harris is Vice President I think
the party is just in a bind and these
the easiest path to this is to Winning
is Joe Biden becoming more popular and
Kamala Harris becoming more popular
through various decisions they make uh
and the economy going well it is it is a
very tough road I think I've not
yes Donald Trump had issues going into
the 2020 election but this is the the
toughest set of of just facts for an
incumbent president facing re-election
that I think I've seen I've been alive
41 years definitely the hardest 60
something percent of Voters saying they
just don't think the person can do the
job anymore that is new and weird
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you
yeah I mean here's I think he just set a
new uh low for his approval rating uh X
months out I've I'm on the record saying
I think there's a recession this year I
think it's already baked uh which is the
best that could happen to buy and if
there's a recession and and there's and
people feel good
next year yeah not as good as that's
true but yeah better than a recession
next year it's true so I I obviously it
was very public saying look the Dem
should have a freaking Democratic
Primary in part because of what you're
describing is like there are a bunch of
candidates who would be much better bets
than Kamala or in my opinion Joe
honestly
um for for 2024 so of the folks who are
prepping these campaigns before the
midterm the campaigns in Waiting the
folks at the DNC would frankly have
knocking on the door being like hey
Joe's out like let me in there as
ideally uh the presidential candidate
but you know maybe kamala's Veep
candidate so the the names I've heard
um certainly Gretchen Whitmer
um as you say in Michigan Gavin Newsom
in California Davey Prince or in
Illinois where the DNC convention will
be held no you know not not so
coincidentally
who are the other folks that you think
would be in that set of uh to be
considered you know you've left the
party so no offense when I say yes for
president uh I bet because I mentioned
people who did run last cycle uh I think
Amy Klobuchar would would be in the mix
again a Buddha judge has a lot of
supporters in local Democratic politics
around the country I know that if you
turn on Fox he's he's I think the most
pinata Democrat in the administration I
mean just him and mayorkas get the most
negative attention for whatever they do
um but I've not seen a poll on him but
he's very well liked among among
Democrats there'd be a question oh can
he drop out of the cabinet and run I
think that would be the type the the
tight feel because there's there's
people who I think are you know
conditioned or sorry position where they
could run uh Phil Murphy in New Jersey
Jay Italy in Washington Cooper North
Carolina Ray Cooper's name I've I've
heard but uh just in terms of he I mean
his record as a Democrat uh as a
Democratic candidate his wind record is
impressive to people but he's not taken
the same I think he's not he hasn't
taken the same organizational steps
sorry not in the scene yeah I mean Phil
Murphy has like a pack that has been
conspicuously spending money
um on behalf of Democrats around the
country not well here's like our field
of Iowa people but like to give he's
been meeting Democrats around the
country Roy Cooper meets them too but
Phil Murphy's like I think people come
away from Murphy thinking he might want
this dude yeah yeah well plus Phil
Murphy has a bankroll to throw around
too you know oh I mean in a way that few
other politicos do JB pritzker is a
billionaire Phil Murphy I think is
probably a center millionaire yeah he
has less money than pritzker does
um but and he has he is finishing up uh
his second term and he's he's out in uh
2025 so that would be the mix of people
and that would be I think that'd be the
conversation if we're just teleporting
ourselves to a crisis in you know August
2024 I think it'd be okay well it's
Kamala Harris and there you know there'd
be a little bit of identity politics
ticket balancing I think of saying okay
well we have
um because this was a conversation I was
a little bit I think I was a little bit
skeptical of you know it was a good one
in 2016 when Hillary was the front
runner the question was can you have a
ticket that's two women uh same thing
when Elizabeth Warren was briefly I was
like okay well I guess we're gonna have
a male running mate when Joe Biden was
running you know famously promises I'm
only going to pick a female running mate
there probably would be a balancing
there of saying we're not let's not say
it out loud but
um there's black female uh Presidential
nominee uh should it be the white guy
governor of New Jersey should be the
white guy governor of Illinois should be
the way the white guy governor of
Pennsylvania
and I think Whitmer and Klobuchar would
be in in the discussion but Democrats
would reckon with all right do we want
an all-female ticket
um we've gotten halfway there we've
nominated you know Hillary we elected
the first vice president what do we want
uh what what do we want to go what's the
image we want to present to the country
when Democrats are looking at the field
and saying okay in normal circumstances
we might be in bad shape but uh Dobbs
but like the alienation that uh the
Republican party has done for Suburban
women maybe that would be fine but it'd
be pretty tight I think fewer people in
the mix so who could be a democratic
vice president than been ran for
president uh in 20 in 2020. I mean you
would not get 26 people in the mix it'd
be who is somebody that voters would
meet and say right yeah they could they
could do the job uh they could be vice
president it would just be some one of
those governors and what somebody ran
before well we all know that the voters
uh voted the top of the ticket and I'm
going to say to you even though you're
saying and you know like a lot of people
say what you're saying is like look they
can't just bypass Kamala but to the
average American they're like Kamala
like President Kamala I'm not pumped
about I wasn't pumped about Veep Kamala
like this President Kamala thing and
polling bears that out uh I'm going to
say I think Kamala loses to Trump you
know I can see the case where Joe can
eek it out uh you know like that that
thing's pretty close but I think kamla
just loses that that race Head to Head
uh I you know and the Dems now are at a
point where it's like well you can like
throw a cycle away you'll be like oh
we'll get them next time you know it is
so
um I you know I think that's like a very
very nasty situation
um it's one reason why I thought that
look just like have a genuine process it
kind of like an emerge
um from a competitive primary Victorious
then you know fantastic she would have
won over a lot of people
um but uh you know I think going with
her as the top of the ticket because you
know you're afraid of
um alienating uh you know like the the
Democrats African-American base uh like
I just think that would lead to uh a
loss in November
um and but yeah you were saying look
um you know a lot of Democrats frankly
see the same thing
um but the question is like would they
just be like well can't you know like
can't uh Overlook the the vice president
you know we you know so let's just try
our best I I think there's a couple
situations one is is what happens in
2028 I think you're right um but
um public opinion is movable and
people have been I mean Richard Dixon
dealt with this the idea of Richard
Dixon is as Presidential nominee in 1960
was even as ludicrous to some people
because of the image he had as kind of a
gopher uh who I didn't really trust
um there would be some image making in
trying to make a couple hairs different
I also think in the situation the night
the nightmare thing I was talking about
for Democrats there would be a lot of
Democrats who say wake up and say okay
well I was you know what what do I
actually think about Kamala Harris as
president let me see the the you know
the let me imagine the memes of the
first female president let me say how
would I feel about her getting sworn in
I think Democrats would be a lot I think
she will benefit from Democrats um
thinking about her as president
it's uh her weaknesses are really just
the things that have that I heard her
campaign in 2020 and the things that uh
really struck staggered her for a lot of
the vice presidency which is that um she
has been assigned kind of unpopular
causes and she has not
um how do I put how do I put it I mean
she she as a campaigner she means she
has a way of kind of like over talking
things saying like saying things that
that Republicans clipped for videos that
may that where they hit they take the
most incoherent 20 seconds
and they just she has not got this
reputation and I've I I've seen this you
know I've seen and been in speeches
where she's rallying people I was in
Nashville uh when she was coming into
Nashville to speak to the state reps who
got kicked out and she can rev up a room
uh but she has been I think defined in a
lot of media and Republican social media
is very good at shaping this as just
like somebody who can't campaign
effectively and it's not going to be it
yeah I've got to say I completely
disagree with your your read
um okay please that's good I'm fine to
disagree because I've been agreeing too
much with you no I know I know I mean
just on this is like because I was in
that Democratic primary alongside Kamala
and she was not underperforming because
the Republicans were like you know like
like misshaping her
um uh her speeches or like clipping
things she just wasn't connecting you
know like I was with her in Iowa she had
the bus and I did not
um you know and and and she dropped out
because it was it wasn't going well
um so like that there there's a real Gap
um and when you talk about hey the
Democratic party were to go with her
there would be all this burnishing and
and star making oh I'm sure there would
be a real effort in that direction
absolutely but but like I I think that
her uh Her Image isn't just frankly an
image I mean there is actually some
reality to these human beings and like
the like you know the the feelings and
takeaways that people have about them
um but I I just don't think that uh this
is something that like a good PR team
and campaign I mean like it's I think in
another era
this is the way it worked it's like you
know Democrats pick someone the machine
said look how awesome this person is and
then everyone's like oh I guess this
person's awesome and then you know we're
into it I mean I think kamala's had
multiple uh stanzas like in the eye of
Democratic primary voters I mean you
know campaign for months uh she was on
you know maybe five debate stages like
people have seen it and felt it uh and
and so she's not some new figure that
you can be like oh like let's make her
awesome
yeah I was I was trying to be careful in
how I described it but I wasn't saying
it was just people memed her out of out
of the out of the race I mean the
exchange with Tulsi gathered which I
think to find her for a lot of people on
the left fine Harris
um was her not being prepared really to
deal with somebody just with nothing to
lose dumping on her uh her prosecutorial
record
um this is a lot you could say about
this I mean the image that she had
um and when she ran for Senate when she
was Attorney General of California she'd
LED on a bunch of of of Criminal Justice
issues uh not just Criminal Justice
Reform but she was seeing she her
critical career started as the tougher
on crime prosecutor who beat somebody
who was less tough on crime she was
going to be smart on crime as her book
said
um just a lot of issues that ended up
not playing like she didn't run on the
the other a basket of issues that she
had known and worked on as a California
politician she defined herself as
something else and it was never a good
fit I mean I think it's probably good if
somebody just can't on a dime change
their entire personality but yeah she
was really flat-footed when she had to
defend stuff that wasn't
um dirigois in the Democratic primary
and uh I mean with one of the first
mistakes she made was she had she agreed
that she supported Medicare for all uh
she was asked about the implications of
of phasing out private insurance and and
she suggested on a CNN Town Hall that
she would and wasn't ready to defend it
like just on those I think she has uh in
the administration it's clear what she's
you know what she what she supports what
she what she doesn't but yeah she was
flat-footed in in a lot of ways in that
Democratic primary she was on on their
game in as a VP nominee in the debate
with Mike Pence she delivered completely
as a as a candidate at the national
stage at that level so that's that I'm
trying to get my head around is that she
had a lot of talent as a California
politician
um she fumbled the ball when she started
running for president it was on issues
that she um you know that were popular
but she didn't really have the um a
passionate about because she hadn't
talked about them before
um but I I I I I don't want to do even
this is very fun speculation but I just
the one thing I think I thought about
that is not obvious is yeah what would
happen because this happens at the lower
level there is somebody who's lieutenant
governor and nobody thinks Blue Heaven
Governor could win on their own or
handle the job they come into the job
people say well I'm I have complicated
feelings about how the governor resigned
or the governor died or the governor
took another job but this lieutenant
governor is really putting it together
in a way that surprises me I think there
is a chance for a honeymoon depending
how this goes but um but no I mean the
the part the party is uh has a front
runner in Waiting who most of the party
thinks cannot win that's the just that's
the gist of it and I think they would
need to just change the facts about
Kamala Harris and she would need to
change people's Impressions and the
facts they know about her for her to be
a competitive candidate that's really
tough it's much more fun for Democrats
to say gosh could we just do a draft and
find a governor he's really good at this
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
I have always been someone who thought
spending a little extra on your mattress
is a wise investment because you spend
let's say a 30-year life on it it makes
you healthier more energized maybe there
are even other people that enjoy your
mattress too whether it's kids or that
extra special someone Helix sleep is the
mattress company we recommend it
includes 14 unique mattresses you can
have a personalized mattress shipped
straight to your door free of charge and
they are so confident they will give you
a hundred night trial yep you can sleep
on it for three months after you take
that Helix sleep quiz figure out the
best mattress for you sent straight to
your door don't trust me alone my kids
also can't get enough of this mattress
Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to Helix sleep.com yang
this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long long with Helix better
sleep starts now
[Music]
yeah someone who's frankly a little bit
uh fresher and undefined in the public
Mind by the way I was standing between
uh Tulsi and kamalo when Tulsi was uh
going after her and that was deeply
uncomfortable because you're like wow
these two are like really savaging each
other while I mean you know like yeah
they were savaging each other yeah but
she didn't have that one response like
there was a way to knock somebody out
who comes after you right and she didn't
do it so that was um yeah it was but
yeah I was literally on that stage
um but but between the two of them you
can you know you can you could look up
that you know there's probably a pick
somewhere of me to like like awkwardly
turning my head back and forth so okay
so that is the the Democratic side field
Good Times uh
um uh on their side on the other side of
the coin uh it looks like freaking
DeSantis has deflated before launching
uh and Trump now is a 20-point lead I
personally know of uh five
um candidates who I think declare in the
Republican field in the next month so
Field's going to grow it feels like it's
Trump's to lose at this point the
indictment seems like it did him a
massive service by coalescing the base
around him and and having him dominate
coverage uh are you seeing and hearing
uh anything different I'm not as the
indictment I did a couple things one uh
yes it did every Republican uh every
Republican who commented on that um even
if they're running against him with the
exception of
ASA Hutchinson said it was completely
bogus it was a front to Justice they
defended him
um that's a major factor helping Trump
in this primary is that just no one
wants to actually attack him uh they if
they do it is some sort of sideways
electability critique like the one Nikki
Haley makes that well you know we need
somebody who can win uh and we haven't
won the popular vote hint hint Donald
Trump didn't win that or it's Vivek
ramaswamy saying Trump is great I Can Do
Better uh or it's DeSantis who remember
when Trump got indicted he offered to
how would I put it I mean he basically
offered to uh not shelter him and find
out
yeah like he was really ready to hide
him out and and be and not not even let
the government bring him in the new if
I'd say New York bring him in uh so they
all defended him
um I think it also and this happens with
a lot of things something is Unthinkable
then it happens I mean one one example
is it was Unthinkable what would happen
if Joe Biden fell down this stairs of
Air Force One well he tripped on the
stairs it happened and then he kept
being president like and think that with
with Trump and indictment I I think this
happened several times to him uh what
happens if he'll be impeached certainly
that's gonna be a crisis and it's going
to collapse him yeah he got impeached
and he got impeached again what happens
if he he it was yet another example of
of trump taking some sort of uh blow
that would destroy I think a governor or
candidate for Congress and then just
kind of forging ahead so every time that
happens
anyone but Trump yeah well but like this
is Biden's benefited from I just
mentioned the stairs but there's a lot
of stuff that has happened that will
come out like accusations or news about
the hunter bite investigation and people
just say uh all right well uh and also
kind of tefloni you're right what are
you gonna do what are you gonna do about
this yeah it's some politicians have
that Trump has more of that ability uh I
think that helped a lot but I think it's
it's um he also has been the most direct
candidate in their field and saying what
he is going to run on he has a policy
agenda I think he's almost written about
too little I like writing about it but I
feel sometimes he'll he'll lay out some
policies that are very far right that
are very close with I think a lot of the
bass Republican party once they do get
broadcast and conservative media they
might not get broadcast for everybody
else I think he just he's run a campaign
that's that's much more that's been
effective at saying put me back in
here's what I'll do and the thing that
yes there have not been you know people
who lost the the presidency and can't
come back in in uh 140 years but the his
basic argument which again every
Republican is running against him is is
um vouching for is that when he was
president things were great things were
good and bring me back and things would
be great these will be good again very
simple I mean you saw in the Washington
Post ABC poll this uh this on Sunday
when people are asked you know who was
better at handling the economy they'll
they say Trump was and if you're a
Democrat you say that's crazy I mean he
he left office us with with unemployment
at eight or nine percent
um the econ like things went to a tail
spin Democrats had to bail him out with
checks to people with with a with a
coveted recovery and Biden has created
more jobs than any president has in not
we I mean preside over the creation more
jobs thing I think Trump has benefited
for benefited from there are not many
people alive who've done this job and
there are things that people uh think
were handled better when he was present
they just are they if uh Republicans
Focus very early on the uh you know the
U.S Mexico border uh that has been a
huge Advantage for Trump of just people
saying I don't remember seeing yet what
was this happening well that's that's a
big issue because the the Trump
Administration uh was it had a very
unpopular immigration policy uh one that
was you know condemned is inhumane by
every Democrat one that was a political
problem for him but it's been kind of
retconned into well we didn't have to
see all these all this footage of 10 000
people at the at the border and this is
much worse Biden can't handle it
um a lot of that I think he's benefited
from a lot of uh rose-colored
reminiscence of I don't remember this
particular problem I don't remember
inflation when he was president I don't
remember
um even things were you know had he been
president and preside over the uh
Afghanistan withdrawal probably would
have gone the same way but he can retcon
that as well that didn't happen I was
President I think he just can do that in
lots of ways so even in the conversation
uh you just shared Dave you're pretty
much fast forwarding to the general and
so one of the things I said to someone
in conversation is that like him or not
Trump is a star and uh the Republicans
uh I the Machinery is having trouble
manufacturing another star in my opinion
they kind of tried to manufacture around
DeSantis into that kind of star and then
it deflated when some more people met
him and we're like wait this dude like
you know like this guy like doesn't have
the personality doesn't have the
Charisma doesn't have the affect he's
had some missteps
um so uh so you're fast forwarding to
the general who has and you know
descendants could turn it around in a
particular Forum I mean he hasn't
declared yet maybe he'll start
campaigning well you know I I'm I'm
dubious uh you know like I am one of the
people that's like look if you're gonna
stop Trump like I don't I mean desantas
might be part of that but I think it's
going to be someone else so I'm looking
at other Republican uh candidates who
have a very very high ceiling
um I think Tim Scott's got a very high
ceiling uh you know um but there's gonna
have to be a massive consolidation
because you already have
um four or five candidates who are out
there I think they're going to be
another five more including uh probably
Governor ASA Hutchinson who you just
named so well he's already running yeah
yeah yeah but Tim Scott's on the 22nd
DeSantis TBD
um and we're uh we're in the sort the
sort of I call like shiny object season
where
um people are not happy with not
everyone but some Republicans are not
happy with uh their options so they're
trying they're kind of wish casting oh
could Brian Camp run could Glenn young
can run not much evidence that like
Republicans want more Alternatives than
Trump and DeSantis right
yeah and young can just said he's not
running so uh it's so so in your mind is
this pretty much like Hey we're gonna
have some debates and whatnot but
Trump's going to steamroll
well the debate's question is
complicated because you might not get
um Trump showing up to the first one or
two debates
um
and I think
Beyond him skipping what's also possible
is a debate where people show up and
they don't want to come uh combat with
him that's what happened in
2015. yeah in that primary there were
Jeb Bush would go after him Rick Perry
would talk about him
um he was really kept off the main stage
uh it's possible that they take the Ted
Cruz approach and just say like look I
know the media wants us to attack each
other but I just want to build on the
legacy of what Donald Trump did
um it's also like the world's not like
the West Wing like sometimes somebody
could be planning except with Chris
Christie's media tour if Chris Christie
ran and he got on the debate stage
everyone has a plan until you get
punched in the face maybe he has a
Zinger maybe Trump has a better Zinger
and that's the end of that
um but I think in the primary I wouldn't
say it's over I just think um from the
polling we've seen Republicans they were
very worried for a few weeks after the
midterms maybe a few months on the
electability factor of okay well this
guy just
help nominate a bunch of losers in swing
States uh and we don't have the Senate
it's his fault but that kind of faded uh
we're back to the art what I was talking
about before which is the the median
Republican thinks things were great uh
under Trump I want them back and they
hear other Republicans say yes things
were great under Trump okay well why
would I vote for you over him I don't
even think you need to get in the weeds
of like are there which five issues they
think you'd be better on it's they need
to be convinced well Trump can't win but
he can and I don't think they're there I
think you need
um some more events to happen for people
to be convinced this poll over the
weekend that I mentioned where uh Trump
is ahead of Biden and as is DeSantis
that's really all Trump needs just to
you know hey the media I can win well
he's already saying you don't need to
trust the polls but if you do if you're
one of the people who don't trust the
polls there's no evidence that I'm going
to lose may I talk to um public opinion
strategies who were very DeSantis
curious and they put a series of polls
out over the last few years uh over the
last few months I should say
um paid for by a non-profit the reports
to Santa saying oh hey there's look at
Wisconsin look at Pennsylvania look at
Arizona DeSantis is narrowly ahead Trump
is narrowly behind and I think something
like the the post poll any coverage of
that
um wipes that off the the Blackboard now
people say all right well no here's a
poll that says he'd win so why should I
pay attention to this other poll
um and look they need there's just not
he's not uh the the current Republican
Coalition there is a core of Voters who
want to vote Republican but don't live
over him but they're not big enough that
they're not a majority of the base the
majority of Republican voters are happy
with them
thank you
I am pumped to announce that I have a
novel coming out on September 12th the
last election it's a political thriller
co-written with my friend Stephen Marsh
who wrote the book the next civil war if
you listen to this podcast Steven's been
a repeat guest even and I became friends
and thought we should collaborate on a
way to scare the out of people but
also entertain them with a story of what
could happen in this upcoming election
or the election thereafter do check it
out at andrewyang.com books and there's
a special discount code last election
that you can use for 30 off at the
Publisher's website I'll be talking more
about this book but I'm so pumped to get
this out into the world last election
coming your way
all right so we've discussed the
Democrats the Republicans and now the
famed other field
um so there's scuttlebutt that Joe
manchin wants to run uh on uh no labels
Unity ticket
um and no labels has uh marched around
the country getting ballot access
preparing for a potential uh 24 ticket
have you heard anything about this like
there's been a lot of press uh bashing
No Labels saying look if they do this
it's gonna enable Trump
yeah
um are you hearing anything about a
mansion uh LED presidential run I
haven't heard anything more than a rumor
on that Mansion how would I put it uh he
has not said enough definitive things
about this I don't think that I think
that no labels wants them I know that no
labels after after Joe Biden sorry after
Joe manchin after Larry Hogan they don't
have any any names that they think would
get immediate media credibility if they
ran as a third party this is what's
happened with other efforts to create a
third party start it up and then have a
candidate on top of it that's what
Americans elect in 2008 uh there's
another effort in um uh no it's a Unity
sorry Unity 08 in 2008
um Americans elect 2012. in both cases
they said what we really like is Mike
Bloomberg to run and then he didn't and
then when he eventually ran into the
presidential candidate so I don't think
um Mansion has not ruled it out but I
think that's because once you rule that
out you lose some leverage it helps
Mansion at the moment where Democrats
were the white White House certainly the
people who the policy folks the White
House who are watching Mansion call for
permitting reform and get angry and talk
about repealing the IRA I think it helps
Mansion the conversation to hint that he
might be the the to not say he would
never run for president I don't think
it's super likely it's also in this
conversation we're having uh Mansion if
there was a race between Trump and
mansion and Biden uh Mansion would be
the uh the third 70-something year old
candidate I mean he's he is at the end
of his political career he maybe he wins
one more term in the Senate maybe he
runs for one more term as Governor but
that's kind of it I mean this is this is
a uh this is the 374 I think yeah yeah
he's in his he's 75 now he's turning 76
to the Stars he would be as old I mean
there's lots of reasons where he's he's
a compelling candidate I think I
underestimated his age oh he keeps he
takes care of himself man I've seen him
you know wearing like the tight like uh
uh coal miners Union polo shirt when
he's campaigning and he's incredible
retail campaigner I've seen that but
president's not a retail campaign thing
so anyway I want to over over egg my
answer I just think it's good for him to
be in this mix
um the problem the labels has confronted
is yes Democrats look uh it's just 2016
2000 Define their thinking
um they will do anything to avoid a
third party a credible third party that
would take votes away or even a less
credible third party I think one thing
we've not um that you and I haven't
talked about but also I haven't heard
much conversation do you see about is
what would happen if
um Robert if candy Jr was convinced to
run as a third party candidate I don't
think he would take that's true I don't
I think most Democrats are so
traumatized by 2016 that they wouldn't
even consider it but that would be one
more problem for them to deal with and
one more I mean what happens I mean
that's incredible yeah go ahead sorry no
that that makes a lot of sense because
he's not going to get a fair shake from
the DNC they're going to be no debates
and he's like hang this I'm going to run
third party I mean that that would be a
reasonable course yeah it's it's
something I remember I know in 20s when
you were running in 2020 that's the DNC
there were critics of its debate
strategy and how it handled everything
but they wanted to make sure that you
were Tulsi gabbard or some democrat with
appeal to Independence did not say screw
this and just run third party
um I mean they got to know you and
they're like oh you're never gonna do
that that's fine like you're not gonna
you're not going to try to spoil this
election
um but that that risk exists and that um
a really helpful group of Voters for
Biden in 2020 were were people who said
they didn't like Trump they didn't like
Biden those voters went overwhelmingly
more than two to one for Biden uh
anything that takes that voter off the
table and and and Parks him with a
Robert Kennedy a Tulsi uh a Joe manchin
a Larry Hogan just naming the people
that they're I've mentioned are in the
conversation any of those voters they
think would be they would be winnable
for a a Biden campaign it's okay you're
not happy but do you really want to go
back to Trump they could park their vote
with somebody else
um they're worried about that so with no
labels they're they're they're serious
about but you even saw and you saw some
of the reporting from Terra Palmieri
this week
um the people who are part of No Labels
don't want to be part of that for the
same reason they don't want to have to
go home and
you know have the kind of conversation
James Comey has all the time was hey man
did you are you the reason that we have
Donald Trump as president uh they don't
want to live live through that so I
think it's a very fraught ex fraught
thing for No Labels to work through
um fraud for it's in the short term not
a problem for Mansion is in the mix he
gets more bookings on TV more people
talk to him
um but if no labels were to actually do
it and get on these dates it's gonna be
it's gonna be knocked down drag out
between Democratic party and no labels
in all these places I even saw it in the
places where they've been getting on the
ballot uh and you've been there with
forward party in some of these places
um yeah for sure yeah how much how much
have you detected Democrats saying like
like what can we do about these people
trying to get in the ballot as an
alternative like how much um oh yeah I'm
trying to kick you off I mean yeah yeah
I I have heard that and and I just do
want to say so no labels is focused on
the presidential forward is focused on
the local like the half million local
races we just had our first mayor
switched to the party in Newberry
Florida so you know very different uh
approaches very very different texts in
part for some of the reasons you're
describing
um but but yeah I like I I did hear from
some folks in Arizona that you know Dems
are uh like very unhappy about
um New Market entrants yeah they are I
mean and in 2004 when Nader was getting
about this as an independent there are
lots of lawsuits to get them off I think
it'd be like that I think Democrats
would uh what options do we have to get
this party off the ballot uh all that
takes time it's a rear guard effort but
the reason they would do it is to say
well we feel better about an election
where there's going to be a lot of
unhappy voters who vote for Biden
because they have no choice uh oh yeah
still yeah that's that's what they
that's they want I think there is going
to be some Republicans who say well I
didn't like Trump but I can put up with
it there will be Democrats who say I
wish there was a younger candidate but
it's Biden that's fine that's already
been happening a little bit but there's
a big share of the country uh I think
it'd be bigger than 2016 that say I just
can't believe these are my choices and
that's going to be a lot of democratic
strategy is that's right right then you
just stick it out with binding these are
your choices wait it out like if we beat
Trump again then you don't have to worry
about them in the future uh not in a
very inspiring campaign but not every
campaign is inspiring I mean it's crazy
we all lived through 2008. I and I I
almost you know I'm not that old you're
not that old but like I'll meet somebody
who's 20 and I'll tell them you know
there was an election pretty recently
where most voters said I like them both
I like both these choices if we've not
been there in a long time
yeah good good times in the USA if only
we had something like ranked Choice
voting and then like you could actually
not have this uh this binary where it's
like hold your nose people hold your
nose
um Dave Weigel how can people follow you
your thoughts uh and your work at
semaphore so I'm on both Twitter and
blue sky if you've heard about blue sky
um with just my name at Dave Weigel I
use those kind of boost where things are
going the website is semaphore.com I
have a newsletter that you can subscribe
to you subscribe to a bunch uh Flagship
Ben Smith media newsletter
um but it's called Americana and it's
it's honestly it's what I did with at
the Washington Post I think it's the
angles a little bit
um I think the angle the angle is the
same it's I go around the country I talk
to campaigns I if there's an issue
that's fascinating that I think is is is
affecting the politics man I wrote last
week about new laws that are going to be
up tested in court about banning access
to pornography for minors the next story
I'm writing is about the race from
Philadelphia
so yeah semaphore.com and the newsletter
Americana that's like all my reporting
from around the country covering these
elections uh Dave I think people should
subscribe because you call it like you
see it uh and you're impeccably sourced
thank you so much Dave we'll have you
back when there there's more
um stuff maybe after this debt limit
Fiasco uh as a result there'll be some
new Fiasco we can unpack
yeah I love I mean this is the weirdest
election that we've lived through and we
could have said that the last four
elections but uh once I talk to you
about it and I hear your your
perspective for having lived through one
of them you know it's there's a lot to
go over so I really appreciate having
the time to go through it with you of
course man I hear last time there was
some guy talking about AI I wonder when
that's gonna be relevant you told you
tried to tell us
you told them like every every every
time I see one of these VC guys saying
hey you know how many people we can fire
how great it would be like I think I
think of uh you warning people in Iowa
that this is gonna happen dude I was
freaking like going to people of Iowa be
like God it's gonna be up to you to
freaking turn this tide yeah and for the
five percent of Iowans who supported me
in the caucus thank you for the rest of
you who just wanted to have a beer with
me
um Mr Chaz this time
but thanks Dave everyone should keep up
with your work uh and would be thrilled
to have you back here thanks I really
appreciate it happy to do it